Okay. Beautiful. Okay. So guys, uh, welcome to our first, uh, not our first training,
but our first training with this format. Um, the reason I wanted to shift to this is because,
and I don't know if you guys follow me on, on social media or I don't care if you do,
if you want to, that's great. If you don't, it's fine. But as I've gotten like more into
business, I've realized that quality is always better than quantity. And I think in the beginning,
when I started my Facebook group, definitely when I had my, you know, my social media,
it was always like, how many likes, how many live viewers can you get? How many group members,
all these different things. And that's just kind of natural as humans. And, um, I realized that,
like, I was talking to a lot of people that weren't even interested in taking action.
And so the whole purpose of doing these kinds of calls is I want to give more value on
to be able to give you guys more value. The people that are receptive and are actually
ready to implement what I'm going to teach today, they're ready to take action. You're the ones that
I want to give priority to. So this is the new format going forward. Okay. Now, just because you
were on today's call doesn't mean that you can't be on next week's call, but we are going to be
doing these live every single Monday. Um, and we're going to be doing them at the same time,
just to keep consistent. The only time that would change is if I am in the air, which I'm going to
try not to do a flight on a Monday. So, um, I know it's a little early for some of you guys.
It's like six 30 for MST. I'm in Dubai. So I'm trying to like, it's like a 10 hour difference.
I'm trying to do my best, but, um, really truthfully, I do not care. And Aaron and I,
when we put up this post, we were like, dude, it was, you know, it's our first time doing it.
And we're like, we probably won't have a ton of engagement because we're going to get this post
up late. And we had like 50 plus people that commented. I don't know if all of them got the
link, but, um, I don't really care about how many people are on this call. And I promise you,
even if one of you, I showed up, I'm going to run this call because I prepared for it. And
that's what I'm going to do. So again, like I told you guys, I'm not going to be posting this
anywhere else. That's just going to be here. So, um, keep in mind guys, what I'm going to be sharing
today, uh, it's not going to give you guys a hundred percent of the information that you need
to build a successful digital real estate agency. Um, like there's no way I can cover that in 40
minutes. And I just want to like start with that. There's no way I can cover everything in 40
minutes period. And, and truthfully speaking, that's why we created digital landlords. Everything's on
the inside. However, um, my goal on this call is literally to do exactly what I did, what I used
to build my, my agency, my rank and rent digital real estate agency to seven figures. And you guys
know that like at the, at the core of what I believe is that we always give value before we
even ask for a conversation before we even ask to like talk about business, talk about doing business
together. We give value and our value is giving them what they want and what they want is our
leads. Right. And so really that like my whole belief is like give ridiculous value upfront,
charge nothing for it, right. Give value. That's so good. Give leads that are so good. They might
even, they hopefully will make money from those leads and like just give them that real,
those real exclusive leads, absolutely free. Right. That's, that's the whole, like that's at
the core of our strategy. And the reason that we do that is because guys, the hardest objection
to overcome, if you've done sales, if you haven't done sales, it doesn't matter, but you'll learn
this. The hardest objection to overcome is trust. I don't care how good your product is, how good it
looks, how good your website is, how nice your polo is and your brand. And if people do not trust
you, they will not buy from you. And that's just the reality. And on, on the flip side, you could
be in your mom's basement. You could look like grungy and not that professional. And if people
trust you, they are going to buy from you. Okay. And so the reason we give the free leads is we
know that the hardest objection to overcome is trust. And that is the very thing that overcomes
trust. So ultimately, when we give leads, our purpose isn't to give leads, just to be a good
person. Our goal is to give free leads so that they will eventually work with us. And that's
the whole strategy. And then we're not hiding that. And I'll tell my business owners, when I call a
business owner, I'm like, Hey, hey, Pete, I want to give you a couple of free leads. Look, just to be
completely straight with you, I want to earn your business. That's my goal here. However, I don't
even want to talk about it until I've given you, until I've let you try out my business at absolutely
no charge. Basically, I'm going to give you some free leads. So guys, I want to let you guys know
upfront that for me, that is no different. I've never hit that. And so at the end of the day,
the reason I have the Facebook group, the reason I add value, the reason I'm doing calls like this
is that I want to earn your business, right? At some point, whether it's digital landlord or
something else that I'm doing, I want to earn your business eventually. Okay. I want you, just like
I want your business owners to be so impressed with your free stuff, with your free leads,
that not only can they not wait to get more, but you leave them or I leave you wondering like, dude,
what would it be like to be able to get on calls with this guy every single week to have access
to this guy every single week to be, have access to that energy every single week inside of his
group, inside of his like inner circle. And so anyway, long story short guys, that is the whole
purpose. And I don't ever want this to come across like I'm this magnificent person that just wants
to give stuff away. No matter what it is, there's always something in it for everybody. And so for
me, I just understand that if you give value upfront without asking for anything,
then the people that are ready will eventually buy. And so that's, that's why I want to do these
more intimate sessions. Cause if you're on this call right now, it's because you are looking to
either take your current business to a new level or to start getting into this business. Okay.
So that said guys, if at any time during this, I think what I'll do, Aaron, can you still hear me
by the way? I don't see. Yeah, you're good. Okay. Cool. What I'll have you do is,
yeah. Are you, does it say your co-host still? Yeah. Okay. Then we'll just leave it like that.
Just keep an eye on stuff and then let me know if you see anything come in. Okay. I got you.
Okay. Guys, all that said, just to get that out of the way upfront, we, it is 42. This is probably
going to be, I'd say 25 to 30 minutes. What I'm going to talk about right now, maybe less.
And then I want to have some time for some questions. Okay. So I want to get right into
what I want to talk about today. And essentially what I want to do is I want to preface this whole
concept of picking the perfect city. And then I want to talk about like the, the, the, the,
the, there's like, to me, I wrote down rules, right? That I have for picking the perfect city.
And so basically I'm going to give you my rules for picking the perfect city.
And they're kind of basically like tips and things that I live by their principles that I live by
when picking the perfect city. So that's going to be the format of this, but this is, I want you
guys to know, this is from somebody that has, I've actually analyzed personally over a thousand
niche and city combinations. Okay. Personally, that's not including my VA's that I trained to
do. However many else I have done this so many times, it's ridiculous. I've looked at so many
cities. I know some of the weirdest cities. In fact, I'll meet people sometimes and they'll be
like, yeah, I'm from Virginia. And then I'll be like, oh, which part? They're like, well,
you don't know. And I'm like, you'd be surprised. And they'll tell me to sit them like, oh yeah,
I know where that's at. And they're like, how do you, I'm like, because I've looked at maps,
like I'm a geography teacher. So I've done this a lot guys. And that's why I know like what I'm
talking about. And I don't want you to trust that. I know what I'm talking about. I want you to put
this into practice and basically like test what I'm talking about. Okay. So a little bit of preface.
Hands down, this is the most important step in the process. And I genuinely mean that if you look at
my material inside of digital landlords, when I built it, I didn't even realize this. But as I
started like recording, like my material of the process I was doing, I'm like, oh my gosh, my
section on niche selection and picking the perfect city, the due diligence process is the biggest
section in our training, which would blew my mind because I never even realized. I thought it was
like maybe the closing or whatever. This right here guys is the most important step in the process,
because if you do this correctly, it makes everything else easier. If you do it incorrectly,
everything else is going to be harder. Okay. So there's a reason why today I'm not starting
off with talking about niches. I'm not starting off with talking about niche ideas, which we may
get into in the future because it's always a fun topic to generate ideas, tell you guys about new
niches. And the reason why, and again, these are just some preface points I want to come up with
and want to remind you of is that I am a huge believer, okay, that you should be going into
boring niches, AKA tried and true niches until you have retired yourself. Okay. And by the way,
when I say retired yourself, that means you have enough money coming in from this model
that your bills are paid for and you no longer have to work a job and everything else is gravy.
Okay. So whatever your number is, if you're a college student and, you know, you live on
ketchup and potato chips, you have a car that's paid for and you live in your mom's basement,
which I, no judgment, you're in a great position. You might only need one deal and then you're
covered and everything else you can go take a chance, you can take a risk on. Until you hit
that point, I'm a huge believer, stick to the tried and true, stick to the boring, because it
eliminates half the equation. You got to get the niche right, you got to get the city right,
you got to get the combination right. So if we can eliminate one of it, which is the niche,
we already know concrete is good. We already know artificial grass is good. We already know that
spray foam is good. We already know that masonry is good. We already know that fencing is good.
We already know that tree service works. We've just eliminated 50% of the equation.
Now we could focus on this part, which is getting extremely good at the city. Okay. So as a reminder,
like if something works, like what you're going to find out is you're going to be okay,
I'm going to follow Nick's advice, and then you're going to get to like 5,000 a month.
Okay. And you're going to realize like, why the heck would I go chase some crazy niche when I
know this works and I can just do it again and again and again and again. And that's what I did
is I was like, I'm going to get to this like certain point. And then I'm going to start
looking at that. Like, you know, the riches are in the niches. I'm going to find that crazy one
no one's ever talked about. And then I got to like 15, 20, 30 and like, dude, I'm just going
to keep going. Like, I don't, I don't care what niche it's in. Just, I care about the money.
Right. So just as a reminder, that's why I'm talking about the city. I'm not necessarily
talking about niche and city. I'm talking about just city because I'm assuming you guys are not
stupid. And I'm assuming you guys are going to listen to what I'm saying and realize, oh,
that makes sense. Let me eliminate half the equation. And I only have to solve half of it.
Focus on the city, go into the boring niches. I'm not saying you have to do concrete, talk a lot
about concrete, but do a boring niche, focus on getting good at picking a city, go get yourself
out of the rat race, retire yourself, quit your job. And now you could start
messing around with new niches. Okay. So, um, a couple more things really quick. I bought a
program back in 2016, my very first program that taught me how to do this stuff. And, um, that
program had an antiquated process for picking a city and niche. It had an antiquated process. And
it to fair in fairness to the person that created this program, I believe that their process at one
point did work. I believe it was really good, probably like three years before. But by the time
I got into it, by the time I was serious about it and I was actually following the advice, it was
antiquated. Okay. Um, a couple of things that were wrong with it. Number one, and you guys might have
heard this in other programs. Some of you guys, I guess a lot of you guys probably bought other
programs and I want you to listen to what I'm saying. You probably will relate. I kept hearing
the same thing over and over. The riches are in the niches, the riches are in the niches,
the riches are in the niches. And I just believed it. I was like, yeah, that makes sense. Right? Like
if I can go into something that no one's ever thought of, I can completely dominate that niche
and I'll just be the only one. And it's completely wide open, blue ocean, whatever. And so guys,
I spent six months doing basically a website in every single niche. You can think of all the
ones that you probably shouldn't go into and all the ones you guys have thought of the plumber,
the HVAC, the electrician, the carpet cleaner, the towing. I mean, all the ones that I hate,
I did because I, I just was told, you know, the riches are in the niches and you need to test all
this different stuff. And I was thinking, I spent hours analyzing niches and looking at home advisors,
different, you know, niche categories and looking at billboards and looking at flyers in the mail
and like so much time. And then I would build, let me try this. Guys, I had this bag of websites
with no money coming in. Okay. That was number one. And so I ended up with basically a website
in every possible niche you could think of with very little money. Okay. And the money that I did
have coming in was in the tried and true niches. Go figure. Right. Okay. And the crazy part is guys,
is I continued on this for like three years from 2016 until the end of 2019. I continued just not
listening to the, like the advice I'm giving you right now and just following that training,
which was like, keep building in niches and you're one day going to find it. And three years in,
I was making eight to $10,000 a month. I was, by the way, making less than I was doing door to door
sales, working more hours. And by this point, I had stacked up 60,000. If you guys don't know
my story, then I, at this point I'm $60,000 in debt. Okay. And like, I just felt completely
hopeless. And luckily I realized this still was the perfect model, but there were just some,
some problems with the training that I was in. And I needed, one of them was I need to figure out
how to pick up the right city and the right niche combination. Okay. And so anyway, long story short,
guys, is that what I realized is that, and this is something you guys need to remember.
If you go into a boring niche, and I'm going to say boring as in tried and true, concrete,
tree service, spray foam, all the stuff we thought of, everyone else has probably thought of it too.
Right. Which means you need to find an obscure or a weird city. Okay. And so what do you think about,
what do you think everyone else is looking at? When they pull up a map, they're looking at all
the cities that you could see. You know, when you pull up a map, you could see Raleigh, North
Carolina, Salt Lake City, Utah, Las Vegas, Nevada, and then you zoom in a little bit more,
maybe it's going to show the next layer. Right. If it's a city you know of,
probably everyone else knows of it. Okay. So just remember if it's a boring niche,
you're going to need an obscure city, a city that no one, that the average person wouldn't
think to look at unless they'd been trained to look like I'm going to train you today. Okay.
And on the flip side is if you guys can do the opposite, which is if at some point you find that
weird niche, then you have the ability to go into more boring or big cities because no one really
is in that niche. Okay. But it's much easier in my opinion, because everyone's trying to focus
on the weird niche and the big city to go into the boring niche and the obscure city, because no one
wants to go into the obscure cities. No one wants to go into Bentonville, Arkansas. Nobody wants to
go into Queen Creek, Arizona. Nobody wants to go into these places because it's not what you hear
of it. It takes effort. It takes knowing what to look for. Okay. So basically guys, I started
testing this. I realized that like, okay, why don't I just focus on the boring niches? Why don't I
focus on the stuff that I know works? Right. And then I'll focus on the cities. And I started
doing this, and I picked one niche at the beginning of 2020. And I said, I'm going to
focus on one niche. That was Tree Service. And I had a bunch of other sites that were ranking
generating leads. I'm like, and I'll try to sell these at the same time. Guys, I focused on Tree
Service. And that is the year that we did seven figures. We went from eight to $10,000 a month in
December of 2019. In July, we did $100,000 a month. It's bananas. Looking back on it, I didn't even
realize the wave I was riding, but it was just working. And I didn't have time to step back and
look at like, oh my gosh, we're growing. I didn't even know we did $100,000 that month until the
month got over. And I started looking at the Stripe accounts. I was like, oh my gosh, we did it.
We did $100,000. And it just continued from there. So this is exactly one of the primary pieces of
the puzzle before I was able to scale is dialing in this process. And unfortunately for me,
nobody could teach it to me because I didn't know anyone that was actually making big money
in this business. They were all making big money selling coaching programs.
But fortunately for you guys, I've done it. I figured it out and I'm going to share it with you.
And so basically what happened from there, guys, to wrap this up,
for those of you that don't know me, seven figures in 2020, just barely over a million. We just
barely passed it. 2021, I did $1.45 million. And then by the end of 2021, my inbox was inundated
with people asking me how the hell I was selling so many deals and had the same training as them.
And I was doing everything completely different because you guys know I do pre-selling.
And I kind of shifted the model on its head and figured this out. And so in 2021, at the very end,
it was like December 1st, we launched Digital Landlords. So that's the story. And that's why
maybe you ought to listen to me. And you also don't have to. So guys, let's talk about
these rules that I have. These are principles that I have. And I would highly encourage you guys to
take notes if you can. Take notes of what I'm about to say because these are principles that
I like legitimately, if I'm doing a city, it has to check these boxes. So I'm just going to
go through these. And then any questions you guys have, I'm going to let you guys ask them.
Okay, so here's these are my principles for picking a good city. Obviously, guys,
like I told you at the beginning, this isn't I want you guys to remember, this isn't like
enough information to just go build a seven figure agency, because I can't cover that in 40 minutes
or, you know, whatever. But this is enough to get you started. To get the wheels turning to get you
guys like thinking in the right direction and putting your focus in the right direction. Okay.
So here's the rules that I live by here, the principles I live by when picking the perfect
city. Again, coming from doing this over 1000 times again coming from making millions of dollars,
not selling my program digital landlords, not doing consulting, but doing exactly what you guys
are doing, which is building simple websites, ranking them on Google, renting them out. In my
case, I like to rent them out, then build them, and then make the money completely backwards,
but you get the concept. Okay. So guys, let's go through this. Number one, guys, and these aren't
in no particular order, but they all matter. Number one, number one rule, number one principle
for picking the perfect city is that population does not matter. Okay, now I know that it in
many courses, by the way, if you are in a course, I promise you I've been in it, I have it. I know
who they are, probably a friend of mine. Maybe not, but population doesn't matter. It's crazy.
The first training I got told me that I should look at population. I can't remember like 100,000
to 250 or 500. It was based on population. Okay. Population does not matter. Here's why.
Let me tell you what does matter. Search volume, the demand, search volume relative,
that's what you guys should remember, search volume relative to competition is what matters.
Okay. Let me repeat that. Population does not matter. Search volume relative to competition
does matter. Okay. And I always give this example. If I were to offer you a website and I said,
I'm going to gift you one of my websites, I'm going to give, I have so many ranking websites
and you've got two options. Okay. Number one option, and this is by the way, it's going to
be an artificial grass. I'm going to give you, you can either get a website that's ranked in,
you know, Manhattan, New York, one of the most populous cities ever, I think. In fact,
maybe I better check. I think it's super populated. Maybe I better check before I give you guys.
Hold on. Okay. 1.6 million people. Yeah, that's good. That's a good example. You can have a
website, you can have an artificial grass website in Manhattan, or you could have an artificial
grass website in Queen Creek, Arizona. Both are ranked, both have a GMB. Which one do you choose?
Okay. Now, this kind of extreme example, and I'm using Manhattan because kind of a concrete jungle,
but the point is that if you're going off population, you'd say all day long Manhattan,
right? But anyone that's like lives in Manhattan or knows Manhattan, it's basically like,
it's like apartments, right? It's completely concrete. I know that there's probably some
outskirts and then whatever, whatever, whatever. But you'd know the point that I'm making. Queen
Creek, Arizona, I think it's like 30,000 population. Let me check. It's growing,
which is another one I'm going to talk about. Queen Creek, Arizona population is 59,000. It's
literally like less than a tenth and like less than a twentieth of Manhattan. And I'd probably
take Queen Creek, right? Because Queen Creek, Arizona is an area that checks all the other boxes.
Got a bunch of people looking for turf because of the climate and because it's growing and because
of just a number of different things. So I want you guys to, and I've looked at the numbers and
I would take Queen Creek, which sounds bananas. It sounds crazy, but that's true. So just remember
as my first principle and what you guys should adopt as well. I guess you don't have to, I hate
to say you should, but you should consider is that population doesn't matter. Okay. Again,
this is from experience. This is not because I read it in a book. Number two, I kind of already
alluded to this, but if you can see it on a map, it's probably not going to be worth your time.
Okay. If you pull up in a map, USA, Australia, whatever, I don't, it doesn't matter guys. This
works in, throughout the world, right? Depending on the city you're in, depending on the, how
people search, how people do business. Not every country is great with this yet, but depending
where you pull up in a map, if you can see the city with that opening view or one or two clicks,
one or two zooms, and I probably would go further and say, if you know about the city,
it's probably not where you want to go because most likely it's what everyone knows. If it's
the Salt Lake City, Utah, if it's the Los Angeles, California, if it's the, if it's the Las Vegas,
Nevada, if it's the Denver, Colorado, if it's the Albuquerque, New Mexico, if you're going to be in
the boring niches, like I suggest you're going to want to go into more obscure cities. Okay. So
it's just a quick rule of thumb. If I know about it, if it's like I could see it on a map,
I'm probably not going to go into it. Okay. That's, and again, that is assuming that you're
in a boring niche. And just a quick reminder that if you're in a boring niche, you're going to need
an obscure weird city. And if you're an obscure niche, you can usually find those bigger cities
because no one's in them. But if you can find both a boring niche, like a tree service and a big city
that's got no competition, you have found literal gold. But I would also recommend that you don't
go chasing it because you, it's not worth your time. You usually stumble upon these things. Okay.
Just so you know. Okay. So that's number one. Number one is population doesn't matter. Number
two, if you could see it on a map, it's probably not worth your time. Number three, certain states,
I'm going to talk about the U S on this one. This is applicable to U S and I would guarantee
this is probably applicable to every country and certain cities, but certain states in the U S
suck for ranking. Okay. Certain states suck. And the number one state, if you guys follow my content,
you probably know it's California. I, if you call me and you're one of my family members and you
want leads, that may change my mind for that specific like specific situation. And I would
still probably like think about it. Okay. Other than that, you're not catching me in California.
I've tried it. I've done it. I've been there and I can't even put my finger on what it is.
I just would recommend, I would just recommend you stay out. And maybe some of you guys are thinking
I'm trying to get you to stay out. So I'm going to go and you guys can check with any of my team. I
have zero websites in California. Zero. Well, I did, but for whatever the case is, it seems like
people are, when you, when you cold call, it's, you know, you try to get someone on the hook,
people are leery because someone's always trying to scam them. The leads just seem to be a little
bit kind of weird. You got people that want to overly check the licensing. It's just a weird
state. And again, I can't tell you why I'm just telling you from experience. I'm not going into
California. It's one of my rules. If it's in California, I'm out. Okay. Certain states suck.
Another state that I find very difficult for whatever reason, only from experience is New
Jersey. I don't know why. I don't know what it is, but those two states have been extremely
difficult. I will not go into California. I won't look at New Jersey, but if I get a referral in
New Jersey, I might look at it. But I know it's not something I'm going to go look at. I also
think it's weird because it's set up weird. There's not, it's kind of like just spread out.
Those two states to me are, are terrible. Okay. Prove me wrong. And I'm sure that you can make
money in California. But the thing I look at is like, yeah, I can, but why? Who am I proving?
What am I proving it to who? Right. So, um, certain states suck, namely California. Okay.
That's number three. Number four, weather and seasonality do actually matter guys.
Weather and seasonality do matter. So one of the things that I do, one of my principles is I look
at the states and cities with, with, by the way, real quick, as I'm going through these principles,
if you have follow-up questions to these principles, please start dropping them in
the comments so that we can start getting, um, those questions, um, so that I can just get
through them at the end. So we don't have like a lag. If you have any questions regarding any of
these like principles, I'm giving you these rules, these laws that I follow, just drop them in the
comments. Okay. Weather and seasonality do matter. This is number four. Okay. I always first am when
I'm looking at a, at a specific niche, I'm going to look at the cities that have, and sometimes
it's not the, or sorry, the states that have the most moderate weather. And unfortunately California
sucks because California is like the best moderate weather. Even with the most moderate weather, I'm
still like the, the state trumps I'm out. Like I, the fact that I don't like to say that trumps the
fact that it's got good weather. Does that make sense? Um, nonetheless, uh, I always look at
states that have like moderate weather. So Florida, Florida, like it, you know, it's got pretty decent
weather year round. Um, Arizona, pretty decent weather year round. Nevada, decent, moderate
weather year round, right? Even parts of Utah. And I know this cause I have a house in St. George,
Utah, which is very close to Vegas, very moderate weather, right? And it, it does get hot. I guess
I might want to even tweak what I'm saying. Seasonality matters, but also like when it, like
try to stay away from places that just dump snow is maybe a less elegant way of saying it, right?
A less elegant way of saying it. Um, but like St. George, Utah, for example, it never snows. And so
people are always pouring concrete. Tree service is happening year round. Does it slow down a bit?
Yeah, but it doesn't stop. Okay. So it does actually matter. So Florida, Arizona, Nevada,
et cetera. Now you guys can, I want to tell you guys this cause let's say you were listening to
this right now and you're like, Oh my gosh, I have this website in this state, in this city,
and I probably made a mistake because you can still get deals. It's okay. I've done it.
What you have to do though, is if you go into North Dakota, heaven forbid you do concrete in
North Dakota, you're going to have to realize in the winter, it's going to stop. And so you're
going to have to sell that deal and you're going to have to set expectations up front that, Hey,
just so you know, like the winter is going to shut off, but you're going to keep paying me
because I'm not going to charge you as much during the hot months. Like you have to,
again, this is something that we cover inside of our training with our scripts, but it's,
you have to position it correctly. Okay. You have to position it very, very well. It is doable. I
would just highly recommend you try to stay away from like extremely cold States. Okay. And the
reason I say that is because like it's, it's just, it's tough. It's tough guys. I'm trying to make
this as easy as possible myself. Okay. Okay. Number five. And this, this isn't, this one kind
of goes hand in hand with, this is more of like a reminder. This kind of goes hand in hand with the
first one, but it's just a kind of a rule to remember is bigger population usually means
more competition. Bigger population usually means more competition, not always, but most often
bigger competition. There's a reason why Dallas is almost always impossible to rank a website.
And so there's a reason why Dallas is going to be one of the hardest places to get your website to
number one, because it's Dallas, it's Fort Worth, it's Arlington, it's this big DFW area. And there's
so many people there that businesses are like, Oh, if I could just be in this area, there's
unlimited customers. And you're thinking that and they're thinking that and everybody's thinking
that. So just remember as the rule, the bigger the population, usually not a hundred percent time,
but most of the time there's more competition. Okay. So what I try to do is I try to find the,
the cities with the least population that still have adequate search for the least population.
And I've found some really small cities. I have a specific project in a city of 30,000 people.
And this thing, it doesn't make me a ton of money. It makes me like, I think like six or seven
hundred bucks a month, but guys, I don't even think I put a backlink on it. I think we just
threw up a website. We rank number one, throw up a GMB, boom, done. And that thing just been
churning out 600 bucks a month for two, three years. Okay. Has enough search volume to get me
that six, seven hundred bucks a month, but it took almost no work. Literally I just built a website
and it's up there. It's done. We're good. Okay. So the bigger the population, usually the more
competition next. Okay. Another rule that I live by another law principle I live by is do not
run away. Do not let me say, do not immediately run away when you see another lead gen site.
Do not run away when you immediately see another lead gen site. Guys, in the beginning of my
rank and rank career, I, as soon as I saw another lead gen site and you guys know what they look
like, they had the quote form and they look kind of bad, kind of terrible. We have like, we're not
designers. We're, we like money, right? We had terrible looking websites. That's why I always
make fun of my websites on my, on my shorts and my posts and stuff. You know, when you see a lead
gen site typically, right? It's a generic name, blah, blah, blah. I used to be somebody as soon
as I saw a lead gen site, I was out. I was like, no, I'm not going to mess with it. And I was like,
gosh dang it, I should have got here earlier. And sometimes I'd even like go down and I look at the
who is I'm like, and I'd find that person in there in my group. And I was like, gosh dude, I hate.
And I occasionally, I even tried to reach out and buy those, these websites, these people just
never worked out. And I like, just turned me away. And then I had an experience and I was in my own
backyard. I was in St. George, Utah. And I was looking at tree service, right? It was when I was
scaling tree service in 2020. Sorry. Yeah. 2020. And I did the research and everything looked good.
Wasn't super competitive, but I saw another lead gen site. Okay. So I clear as day, another lead
gen site. And I was just this close to just like being like, I'm not going to do it. And then I was
like, you know what, maybe I'll just reach out. And I found out who it was. Sure enough, they were in
one of my other groups, following the same training and whatever. And I was pissed. And I was like,
you know what, I'm just going to reach out because I know who it is. I found them on Facebook. I'm
like, Hey, are you interested in selling your tree service site in St. George? Just so you know,
I live here. And they couldn't have been more rude. Not only were they not interested in selling
me the site, but they were not interested in even having a conversation. They were not even
interested in being an acquaintance of mine. They just felt me like to be a threat. And honestly,
what happened is that pissed me off so bad. It really, really pissed me off that they like treated
me like that, that I did it in spite of that. I literally did it in spite. I was like, okay,
game on, game on. They were like number two. I was like, I'm going to be number one. And out of spite
for this person, I went ahead and went into the city and built a website,
got a client and had one of my best clients. I signed this person in 2020 March. I still remember
it was like mid-March, right in the middle of COVID on the hood of their truck in a gas station
parking lot. I swear to you, this is a true story. We had talked on Zoom earlier and then she had to
talk to her husband or vice versa. No, I met him at a coffee shop. She talked to me. I swear to
you, we met at a gas station and we signed a physical contract for the first month in March
2020. It was one of my best clients ever. And they stayed with me for a long time. They eventually
went on to do their own stuff like a few months ago, but they kind of outgrew what I was doing.
They wanted to just expand. But literally, I would have missed out on, I think I made, what was that,
over $20,000 because I almost ran away. Okay. So what you guys have to remember
is just because you see another lead gen site, don't assume that that website's getting leads.
Number one. Okay. What I mean by that is like, just because you see another lead gen site,
doesn't necessarily mean you should go into that city. It doesn't mean they are getting leads. So
it doesn't mean that like, yeah, that's a guaranteed, you should go to that city. Number
two, don't assume because you see a lead gen site that they have a client. In fact, most of the
time I would be like, pretty much assume they don't have a client. And that was the case in
St. George tree service. I actually called the website or I requested for a quote and nobody
answered. And then I did it like two or three times, nobody got back to me. And that's why I
was like, let me reach out to these people. Don't assume they have a client. Okay. What you guys,
and some of you guys might be in other programs, look at our free Facebook group. We have 6,000
members. Do you know that in over half of the people in that group, in our free Facebook group
have already learned the skillset of building a website and getting leads. They're probably in
one or most of them are probably in, most of you guys are probably in one to two other groups.
And the problem is, is just because you could build a website, just because you can get leads,
does that mean you're going to make money? Guys don't assume because someone has a ranking website
that they are working with a client. Okay. And thirdly, do not assume that two people
cannot have two different clients in the same city. Even if they do have a client,
why can't you work with Bob and I work with Joe?
You can, it doesn't matter. It's just another website. We get so scared. We think that,
who cares? What I do is if I see another lead generator, I just take that website and I view
it just like any other website. I pretend it's Bob, the freaking concrete guy. And I look at
his backlinks and I look at the age of his domain and I look at his content and I look
how his website structured and I look at his GMB and I assess it just like it was Bob.
That's it. And if it still works, if the numbers, if the competition is still low
and the search volume is still there and everything else checks, dude, I'm going into it.
I could care less or I couldn't care less. I think I couldn't care less how you say it.
Okay. Don't immediately run away when you see another lead generator site.
Okay. I got one more. Try to, this is my last one and I actually have a bonus one really quick.
Try to find areas that are growing rapidly statistically. Try to find areas that are
growing rapidly statistically or that are statistically growing rapidly. I don't know
how the best way to say that English is. Okay. And I'm telling you this because if you know of
areas that are growing rapidly, whether it's because of data you've seen, family members
that live in those areas, you've traveled there for other jobs or vacation, knowing this information
about cities will allow you to look at cities and confidently go into cities you never would have
confidently gone into before. Even when everything else doesn't look so perfect.
Okay. Let me give you two examples. Number one example is Bentonville, Arkansas.
I lived in Bentonville, Arkansas, selling door to door home security systems. I saw how many houses
were being built. I saw the construction companies. I saw how many families were moving into
Bentonville, Arkansas. And I knew that the reason they were moving into Bentonville, Arkansas
is because Walmart was headquartered there. And Walmart had a policy that if you want to sell to
Walmart, you needed to have a office in Bentonville, Arkansas. Who knows about where? Bentonville,
Arkansas, you need to have an office there. They're that big. They can demand an office.
And so I was like, okay, Walmart's not going anywhere. And the guy that works for Jack
links lives over there. And the guy that works for Pepsi lives over there. And the guy that
does this. And I was like, this place is just going to keep growing. And I statistically
was looking at some of the data with how it grew. And I was asking people, what was the recession
like? They're like, dude, we didn't even feel it. And I saw just new construction after new
construction. And I knew, because I spent time there, this place was going to explode and continue
to grow. And it's continued to explode. Okay. And when I did the research on this area,
the numbers weren't perfect. They weren't so good that I was just thrilled. I might have even
skipped it. First of all, I wouldn't have even looked at it. Second of all, I probably would have
skipped it if I hadn't have lived there or known about it. And, but because I knew about it, guys,
I went in and build a website. You guys know, I've talked about some of that Bentonville
concrete.com. And that site has made me so much money. It was so easy to rank. It was like the
most perfect golden website ever. But one of the biggest reasons, because I had information,
this was actually like first-hand information, that this city was rapidly growing. Okay. Another
example of St. George, Utah, ironically, where I live, I, it's the same type of thing that the
city is just exploding. The population when I built St. George tree service was not that great.
And I was like, no, man. In fact, I avoided my own city for a long time, because I was like,
everybody's cheap and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. I don't want to sell the people that I know.
And I was like, you're being an idiot, Nick. And in 2020, I built like three, four websites
that made me over a thousand dollars a month each in my own backyard. And at one point,
I think we were doing like close to $10,000 a month in my own backyard from niches in my own
backyard, but that I'd completely skipped. But I finally was like, dude, look at all the growth,
look at all the houses, look at all the construction companies, look at wherever all that.
And it just was like, duh, you're such an idiot, Nick. Okay. Try to find areas that are rapidly
growing. Okay. And if you can get statistics, great. If you know first-hand information from
family members, friends traveling there, or you've been there yourself, even better. Okay.
My bonus tip, my bonus rule. Okay. And this is something that like doesn't have to be checked,
but it's, it helps a lot. That's why I want to give it to you guys is knowing the demographic
and the area. Okay. Which kind of goes hand in hand a little bit with what I just said,
but if you guys can know a little bit about the people that live there, right? A little bit about
the people. I'm a, I'm a big believer that humans are humans are humans. Meaning that like, if I,
you know, like, for example, humans, what's a good example? Like for, like if I'm somebody in Utah
that likes groceries delivered to my house, it's pretty likely that you living in Connecticut,
you also like groceries delivered to your house because you don't want to go to the grocery store
and waste your time and potentially get, you know, sick or whatever the case is, right?
Humans are humans are humans. However, I have learned that from state to state, city to city,
definitely country to country, there are nuances. And the more you know, the better decisions you're
going to make. And let me give you an example. In bed in Northwest Arkansas, there's a city called
Bentonville. I just talked about an hour and a half, maybe two hours south. There's a city called
Fort Smith. Okay. Just, I think about two hours. I've been there a few times. And I will tell you
that the, the difference in the people is so, is so different. It is, they're still from Arkansas.
They're still a Southern ish. I'd call them more Midwestern, but technically we say Arkansas
Southern. But guys, for some reason, people that live in Fort Smith have this old school mentality.
It's good old boy. We only do business with people that we know. And when we want to do business,
we ask for referrals and that's it. And we don't want anyone new in our town. And if you come into
my town, I'm not that interested in talking to you. That's how the mentality is. It's two hours away
from Bentonville. And guess what? In Bentonville, no one's from Bentonville. No one, everyone's from
somewhere else. And they're, they've been implanted because of work. Another example,
St. George, Utah, where I live. Okay. Tons of people moving in, but in my cul-de-sac,
where I have a house, my next door neighbors from Northern Utah. So they're from same state,
but like four hours away. Then the other two people in my cul-de-sac, one from Texas,
one from California. Okay. Like everyone's from not there. Like, and I'm not from that city either.
I'm from Utah, but I'm not from that city. Everyone's moved there for work opportunities,
for the weather, for recreation, whatever. And because I knew that I'm like, okay, confidently,
I know that if people are from California or people are from Texas, you know, they're probably
going to be more likely to spend money. One thing I know about people from Utah, because I've lived
there, is that in small towns in Utah, people are very cheap. People would say, do anything to save
$5. I swear to you, they would drive across town, not thinking they're going to spend $15 in gas
to go to get a $5 coupon redeemed. And I swear to you, I'm not making that up. If any of you guys
on the stream that are from Utah, you guys can verify what I'm saying. So I knew that the city
that I lived in, St. George, wasn't really Utah people. It was mainly like people from out of state.
45 minutes up the road, there's a little city called Cedar City, Utah, which I went to college
in for two years. And that place is basically only people from Cedar City. And guess what?
No one wants to spend money. You want to charge what to pour my concrete? Nah, dude, I'll just go
get the bags at whatever and get people from my church to come help me. You want to pay for moving?
I'm not paying for moving services. I'm certainly not going to have you pressure wash my driveway.
I'll just go buy a pressure washer. I'll do it myself. Like, this is the mentality of these
people that are 45 minutes away from the city of St. George in a city called Cedar City.
It's insane. And so the hard part is, if you don't live in those areas, you don't know that.
But when you know that, it changes the entire game. So you have to remember, the more information you
can get on these cities, the more information you can get when you call business owners. Because when
you're calling business owners, Nick notes, how did that one act? Oh, that one acted like he didn't
even want to talk to me, like I had a disease. And then the next three were the same. Okay,
maybe there's something there. Right. So guys, just remember that knowing the area and the
demographic people does matter. Okay. So let me give this quick recap on these different laws
of picking the perfect city. And then I'm going to go into Q&A. So number one is population does
not matter. Number two is if you could see it on a map, then it's probably not going to be worth
your time. Number three, certain states suck, namely California and New Jersey. Number four,
weather and seasonality do matter. Stay out of places that are extremely cold if you can.
Number five, bigger population usually equals bigger competition. Number six, don't immediately
run away when you see another Legion site. Number seven, try to find areas that are growing
rapidly. And then my bonus tip is the more you know about the area, the more you know about the
demographics, the better decisions you're going to make. Guys, these are things that I have learned
because I have literally looked at a thousand locations. I've gone into
hundreds of the wrong cities, hundreds. And I mean that like we had well over 200 websites at one
point in inside of my business, in all different cities, in all different niches. And we made our
million dollars off of like 40 websites. Yeah. So you guys have to realize that like all these
people that are giving you advice, build, build, build, build, build, build, build, build, build,
most these guys are selling you tools to build. Most of you guys, most of those guys are making
money because you are building more websites, right? I'm not selling you tracking numbers.
I'm not selling you websites. I'm not selling you hosting. I'm not selling you that stuff.
I don't. And that's not how I roll. I want to build a website that's going to work. I want to go.
I want to run ads. I want to get the deal. And I want to be a sniper. I don't want to take a
shotgun and just shoot bullets. That's messy, right? It's just some heavy cleanup. I want to
be a sniper. And if I decide to go into that city, it's one shot, one kill. I know what's
going to happen. I'm most likely going to get that deal. I know I'm going to get that deal.
I'm going to build a website and I'm going to have a really clean business. I'm not just throwing
stuff at the wall, hoping to see what sticks. Okay. So that said, guys, who has questions?
Let me see if there's anything in the comments. We got some stuff in the chat.
Here we go. So just for the sake of time, I'm going to go ahead and just read through these
in the future. I'll try to leave more time. We can have you guys come on live. So
Jay says he's in Jersey. Jay, prove me wrong, but I promise you Jersey. I don't know what it is,
man. It's a weird state. Okay. Kirk says, I'm not sure what you mean by relative to competition.
Can you give an example? So what I mean by that is like,
so let me read your entire comment to make sure I know exactly. I'm not sure what you mean by
relative to competition. Can you give an example? E.g. volume 50, then what would too much competition
look like for that volume and location? So that, again, as I said in the beginning,
we're not going to be able to cover all of that in this 40 minutes. That's part of what we talk
about, our formula for picking a perfect city in terms of competition. We're just talking about
about like my rules of picking the perfect city. But what I mean by that is like, you want to get
into a city. What matters is having enough search volume while still having low competition. And
what I mean by low competition, guys, is the ability to rank your website. Right? If you look
at Las Vegas, Nevada, tree service, there's probably going to be a ton of search volume,
but it's also going to be a lot of competition. Okay. If you look at Las Vegas, Nevada,
tree service is going to be a lot of search volume. There's going to be a lot of competition.
Right. We want to go into cities that have good search volume. They're probably not going to be
as high as Vegas, but there's almost no competition. That's the sweet spot. Right.
That's what I call a layup. Hopefully that makes sense. And again, to answer that specific question,
the like the volume and all that stuff, that's something that we that's like, it's a much
heavier question that we cover in more depth in inside of our thing. But Mark,
what's your take on a town of 40,000 with search volumes of 10? So the tricky part of the search
volume thing, we're going back to like also what Kirk said, is it depends on the tool you're using.
Right. Because I don't know what tool you're using and you what, basically I'll give you like the
overview with, with tools, they're all wrong. Like nothing's accurate period, just so you know,
like nothing's accurate. All you're doing with tools is you're finding benchmarks. You're finding
out like how, okay. You know, Bentonville, Arkansas, concrete, I'm ranking number one
for all these keywords and I get 30 leads per month for the last two years. Okay. Boom. So
how much, what does that tool say about Bentonville concrete? Well, it says that there's only
50, sorry, it says there's 15 searches. Well, that's not true because I'm getting 30 leads.
Right. So then I can safely assume that if the tool says 15, it's probably double. Right. So you
kind of have to find a benchmark and go off that. So I can't answer that question based on that data,
but what I would tell you is like 40,000 is on the lower end and 10, no matter what tool you're
using seems low. The other thing you have to consider, which I probably would add, I would
definitely add into this, but I don't, I don't want to get too much into weeds because that's stuff
that I cover when you have to have the full picture is you need to know what the CPC is
because if it's, if it's a search volume of 10 and there's zero cost per click,
then that probably means no one even wants that traffic.
And I don't know if that makes any sense to you, but I can go into that in more depth, but yeah,
that's going to be too hard to answer. I would say just my gut tells me that's not enough
volume. You got to have adequate search volume. Guy Prantz, same thing. You guys are asking really
good questions. This is one of those things like, again, that it's tough to answer unless
you know exactly the entire process. So adequate search volume basically means taking a website
that you know for a fact is ranking really well, looking at the numbers of that in terms of how
many calls it's getting, comparing that with the tool you're using and using that as a benchmark.
And you have to do that repeatedly. You have to do that because the tools change, the search volume
changes, and you kind of constantly have to be doing that. And so, and at the end of the day,
it's not entirely a science. It's more of an art. And by doing this a thousand times,
you kind of recognize these patterns. Okay. Laura says definitely done that.
Kirk, how do I benchmark a niche location when I don't have a site there? You guys can use,
if you want to ask this question, Kirk, inside of the free group, you can ask this question.
Like you go make a post, and then Aaron, I'll have you remind me to look at the data on,
we could say Bentonville concrete, and I can kind of give you a city that's ranking really well,
and you could use that to benchmark if you guys want. Okay. Howard says, does median income
matter? If so, what's the average income threshold you're aiming for? I think it's a factor. To be
honest, I've never really looked at it. I just know like certain states are like usually not
as well to do. Like I know Mississippi is a very poor state, just statistically. And so I've,
in fact, I've only done one website in, I think, was it, no, that's in Louisiana.
Maybe I haven't done anything in Mississippi. I just kind of stay out of states that are like,
it sounds bad, but like, I don't have to go into Mississippi. I can be that way. I don't have to
go in there. I can, whatever. So it does matter. I've never really like looked at it too much. I
think it's more about just like, I don't think you need to worry that much about it, but as a
state, if it has like kind of a stigma as being a poor state, I probably would avoid it. Okay.
Jay says, so should I just start in Bentonville? You can. You definitely can. And guys,
funny thing is I'm so not the person that gives a flying you know what about like,
guys, I'm telling you guys which cities I'm in. I'm not hiding anything. I'm telling you the
niches. I know I'm telling you the web. Like I have videos on, on YouTube. You guys could see
website examples. And the reason I do that is because if I'm taking care of my client,
I shouldn't have to worry, right? It's like being married to someone and being worried that like,
if you introduce them to your handsome friend, she's going to leave you. That's the wrong person to
be married to, or you're not, you're not bringing, you're not pulling your weight. So I don't worry
about that stuff. So I'm, yeah. So basically, Jay, if you want to go to Bentonville, dude, check it
out. It's a great city. St. George, Utah is a great city. Queen Creek, Arizona. I'll share that
with you. These are great cities. They're growing. You can also do a Google search and type in like
fastest growing cities for the last five years in the U.S. and get the same thing. So, you know,
but keep in mind if it's Bentonville, I probably looked at it as well.
Jason, you're 100% New Jersey is highly competitive and saturated. Very difficult.
Interesting. Beautiful. Guys, thank you for being on. I appreciate you guys being on. I love this.
I don't know even how many we ended up having on, but let me see. We got Paul,
Mark, Ferranc, Lara. What I want to do, Aaron, can you hear me still? Hop on really quick before
you guys hop off. So what we're going to do guys is Aaron's going to, he's been on this call. He's
going to create just like a simple, like PDF with these rules, like a really like nice looking clean
PDF. And anyone that was on this live, I'm trying to think how we could, what you're going to do,
Aaron, can you like screenshot everyone that was on this live somehow? And I want you to
send this to them. So if you guys were on this, just because I appreciate you guys staying on
to the end, if you're on here right now, then Aaron will DM you from the Donnie Dre. We tried
to do that so Aaron doesn't have to be inundated with messages on his private one. He's going to
email you like a nice looking like document with all the stuff I went over today. So if you guys
were on there, stay on. Did you screenshot it yet, Aaron? Yeah, you're good. Okay. Last question
I'll answer really quick is, is the search volume good enough if the Google ad forecast shows 84
clicks with a budget of $20 a day? I don't look at that metric and I never have, so I couldn't. I
look at the search volume versus the CPC versus the competition. And again, the competition thing
is kind of one of those formulas that we teach, that I teach inside of my program, but I could
cover it in more detail. Again, I want to give you guys as much as possible. It's kind of like
the free leads thing. Like I want to give you guys, I want you guys to be able to take what you
learned today and be able to get started, right? Just like we don't want to give our business
owners leads and, well, here's some leads, but I hope you don't make money, right? That's stupid.
I want you guys to take this. If you guys make money from what I teach you today,
you'll be back next time. So amazing questions, guys. Appreciate you guys being on and we'll be
doing these every single week. So keep an eye on the Facebook group and we've got some other stuff
coming up this week as well. So thanks guys. I'm out.